I came across this real headline on
people.com this is real Andy Richter
shuts down plane passenger who puts bare
feet with dirty toes on seatback TV this
was a trend that this was the number one
trending story on People magazine
dot-com last night true story Andy what
hat what happened I was on a flight and
we are at the front of the plane and a
guy put his bare feet up on either side
of the TV screen I actually I treated it
I think he took a picture yeah I took a
picture of it and I took the picture
just to send to the people that I liked
- [ __ ] - yeah and just to say look
check out this creep flight attendant
says please put your feet down sir he
puts them down then a couple minutes
later he puts them right back up and so
me being the [ __ ] that I am I was
like hey buddy could you do us all a
favor and not put your bare feet where
people touch things with your hands it's
a hygiene question your bare feet man
and he got indignant and we put him down
for a second but then he put him back up
sort of stubbornly so I thought screw
this I'm tweeting it yeah and so I I put
it on screw this I'm tweeting it or some
of the bravest words ever spoken
yeah I think I'm the real hero yeah
right up there with anything said during
the civil rights struggle right you know
I mean yes it's it's a disgusting thing
you got I mean lots of people responded
to it because they are disgusted what's
the big deal
[Music]
last um and that's Tony our cameraman
come on Andi everybody Buzzard
Tony let's see I'm sorry that's gross
come on using my feet to operate the
camera frees up my hands for talking you
know I use my hands a lot when I talk
you ever think about that yeah but it's
still disgusting I mean nobody wants to
see your feet and other people touch
that camera come on stop being so
elitist you'll shut up gonna come over
there and punch you with my feet
Tony punching with your feet that's
called kicking okay oh la la listen to
you too fancy poet pants no it's called
kicking Tony how about I kick in with my
fists which are free because I'm using
my feet top rate the camera
Touche Tony that's great yeah I don't
know what you just said but shut up
right there I'll slap you across the
face with my size 13 Tony take it easy
we're just gonna take a little break
we'll continue with the show
hey Conan you're supposed to say that to
my camera what okay all right yeah
all right okay this to this camera here
yeah all right well we're gonna take a
little okay all right we're gonna take
we have a great show from from pitch
perfect 2 and Ralph breaks the internet
after and world-renowned DJ Flula Borg
is on the show come on my toes hurry up
all right doing it it's very funny
comedian mohan adele shaky is on the
program
[Applause]
[Music]
you